Salve youtubers questo è un video
ringraziamento per i 10.000 iscritti
Madonna se ci penso
10.000 iscritti che per molti potrebbero
non essere nulla perché molti dicono
sono solo numeri su internet ma secondo
me non è vero 10.000 iscritti vuol dire
che ci sono 10.000 persone che seguono i
miei video
10.000 io non so neanche come
ringraziarvi Cioè dovrei dire mille cose
Sparare le salite frasi banali che
dicono tutti tipo Grazie mille Siete dei
grandi Siete dei siete I magnifici Siete
i migliori ma è tutto così banale tutto
così scontato che c'è solo una cosa che
posso dire
Grazie e il vostro feedback diretto È
qualcosa di straordinario che non
Infatti non riesco a spiegarlo parole
molti penseranno Eh guarda questo che si
monta la testa adesso 10.000 iscritti
Guarda che non sono niente Beh pensatelo
un po' Come volete io vi ringrazierò
dall'inizio alla fine e infatti per
ringraziarvi ho indetto un nuovo
concorso oggi si apre la partecipazione
al mio concorso semplicemente postate
una recensione di quello che volete qua
sotto le regole sono molto semplici e
sono più o meno sempre le stesse non c'è
il limite d'età e c'è il limite di una
parte soltanto di video Quindi al
massimo 10 minuti o se siete partner di
YouTube più minuti deve essere una
recensione e sottolineo di quello che
volete e come volete seria divertente
semiseria a coppie singoli a gruppi orge
animali stupratori prostituti
Vabbè avete
capito altra Regola fondamentale vi
dovete far vedere in faccia Vi voglio
vedere vi voglio vedere perché voglio
vedervi voi 10.000 voglio Beh non
parteciperete in 10.000 però quelli che
parteciperanno li voglio vedere perché
io vi devo ringraziare io non posso
ringraziare un testo un video fatto a
testo con Movie Maker o con World No
voglio vedere voi e quindi per
ringraziarvi voglio conoscervi veramente
quindi ripassiamo un attimo di nuovo
alle regole fondamentali uno non deve
essere più lungo di 10 minuti o comunque
di una parte sola du dovete vedervi in
faccia Cioè devo vedervi in faccia
quindi dovete filmari voi tre deve
essere una
recensione di qualcosa di qualsiasi cosa
quattro ripeto deve essere di qualsiasi
cosa
sia divertente che seria potete farla in
qualsiasi modo con chi volete da soli o
in compagnia non è importante cinque non
c'è limite di età io voglio vedere cosa
riuscite a fare senza organizzarvi molto
voi dovete riuscire a improvvisare
perché quando vi scrivete le cose vi
preparate le cose le cose vengono male
dovete
improvvisarti di video o immagini o
musica non è importante c'è molta gente
che fa recensioni soltanto parlando
davanti alla telecamera senza mettere
nessuna immagine Sono bravissimi
ora veniamo al premio del concorso come
sapete cioè non ho fatto in tempo a
finire il il concorso prima che siete
arrivati a 10.000 e purtroppo non sono
ancora riuscito a a dare il premio tra
virgolette a fare il video con il
vincitore del vecchio concorso ma
purtroppo Ras Player 911 in questo
periodo ha gli esami di maturità quindi
gli faccio un saluto e gli cioè Gli
auguro un in bocca al
lupo e quindi purtroppo per questo
motivo non riusciamo molto a beccarci io
so che lui la sera c'è ma io purtroppo
la sera devo fare determinate cose ho da
fare determinate cose quindi non ci sono
sempre e purtroppo quando io non ci sono
lui c'è quindi non riusciamo bene a
beccarci ma comunque lo faremo eh non
non vi preoccupate Anche se dovessi dare
decretare il vincitore prima di questo
concorso Comunque poi lo faremo quindi
raspay non ti preoccupare lo faremo
riprendiamo il discorso il premio di per
questo concorso il premio per questo
concorso sarà
ehm una
una una statuetta di Firenze
No un set di cacciaviti piccoli piccoli
per avitare le vita le avitare le viti
de degli
occhiali il giocattolo del mio
cane una caramella un liquido per pulire
gli occhiali una brochure dell'hotel
Riviera a
Spotorno cosa mi invento cosa mi invento
un rotolo di scotch di carta una
pila usata
Ragazzi la verità è che non so cosa
darvi come premio ve lo giuro Cioè oltre
ovviamente a pubblicizzare il canale del
del vincitore Non ho idea di cosa
regalarvi perché non so se spedirvi
qualcosa a parte che non saprei cosa
spedirvi perché magari a qualcuno non
piace a qualcuno sì quindi si creerebbe
confusione ma soprattutto non so se vi
arriverebbe perché con il casino che c'è
delle poste dei soldi ehm dell'arrivo è
un po' un po' complicato quindi non so
se arriverebbe fare un video
insieme cerco di evitarlo di nuovo
perché come si è visto con Ras Player la
cosa poi si potrebbe protrarre nei
secoli dei secoli e quindi non non si
finirebbe più però mi dispiace fare
soltanto la pubblicizzazione del canale
perché di solito già lo faccio Quindi e
non lo so nel corso del del concorso
penserò a cosa magari un premio più
decente magari un disegno Non lo so
adesso vediamo Mi dispiace molto non
dirvelo subito ma veramente ve lo giuro
Non ne ho la più pallida idea Comunque
se voi volete partecipare partecipate
Spero partecipiate numerosi ci la La
finale sarà esattamente come nel
concorso scorso ci saranno i finalistii
i finalisti e il vincitore quindi spero
non Cioè spero partecipiate in tanti ma
non così tanti da bruciarmi comunque
Partecipate in quanti volete le regole
le ho detto prima le scriverò nelle
informazioni del canale e quindi ancora
Grazie mille per questi 10.000 iscritti
saluti